Game of Thrones Season 6 episode 3 is
out and there's a heap to talk about so
let's begin at the wall Jon Snow rises
from the dead and people think he's the
prince that was promised or azor Ahai
reborn a messianic figure prophesied to
save the world from darkness basically
kind of a game of Thrones of Jesus and
John is pretty Jesus he isn't he a
righteous man betrayed by his friends
killed before a cross risen from the
dead great hair sweet abs it's not super
clear what being this savior means but
it seems to involve fighting the White
Walkers and their whites also Melisandre
asks John where he went and what he saw
when he was dead and John says nothing
Mel has a similar exchange with beric
Dondarrion when he's resurrected three
seasons ago maybe part of why Melisandre
is so interested in death is that she
herself has been fleeing death for
apparently several centuries maybe she
fears death and that's why she asks
about it so intently
anyway the similarity between beric and
John suggests that their resurrections
work by the same kind of magic but when
barrack is resurrected he changes loses
bits of his memories and identity when
John comes back all it takes as one of
Devils as legendary pep talks and he
seems about the same as he ever was so
is John truly unchanged by death or will
we see new sides to his character this
season then were on a ship sailing south
we see Gilly being cute and Sam being
not so cute the plan is for Sam to join
the maesters of the Citadel in old town
which is like a sort of a University
where Sam can learn the knowledge he
needs to help the watch maybe he'll find
some info on White Walkers
but since the Citadel doesn't accept
women Sam will be dropping Gilly and the
baby off at horn Hill with Sam's family
he mentions his mother Melissa who is
kind and his sister Taylor who is lovely
and his father Randall who is neither as
Sam explained in season one Randall was
horrible to sam growing up cursing
caning slapping and starving him to try
to toughen him up into the strong brave
son he wanted instead of the soft
cowardly son he got eventually Randall
threatened to kill Sam unless he gave up
his name and inheritance which is how
Sam ended up
the watch and now Sam is coming home
bringing Gilly and a baby who they're
saying is Sam's when it's actually
Craster's manses in the books cuz
there's a baby swap lot going on but the
point is that this is going to be like
an epically awkward meet the parents
type situation except that DeNiro is a
battle-hardened War veteran Ben Stiller
is a fat watchman who killed an ice
monster and his girlfriend is a wildling
with an incest baby so basically this is
gonna go off on another note in the show
Maester Aemon died last season at the
wall but in the books maester aemon
comes along with Sam and Gilly on this
voyage and he dies on board the ship
there's this beautiful moving scene with
a maan crying in the rain remembering
his youth depicted here by artist kay
Huang see the link in the description
for more of his art then beyond the wall
bran has a vision of the Tower of joy
this event happened about 20 years ago
at the time of Robert's rebellion the
war where Robert Baratheon took over
Westeros from the Mad King Aerys
Targaryen after the Mad King son Prince
Rhaegar ran off with Ned Stark's sister
Lyanna
who we saw as a child lost episode at
this point in the war both of the Mad
King and Prince Rhaegar have been killed
so Ned Stark and a group of his men
including Meera and Jojen father Howland
Reed have come looking for Liana at the
Tower of joy they find the tower guarded
by three Kingsguard two Kingsguard in
the show including the legendary
swordsman Arthur Dayne they talk about
the war the dialogue is kind of cooler
in the books and then they fight with
Dayne pretty much kicking all their
asses he would have killed Ned - if
Howland hadn't stabbed him in the back
at the last moment so that Ned could
finish Dane off it's upsetting for
browne disease father act in this
dishonorable way Ned had this seemingly
untouchable reputation of honour and
honesty but if he didn't tell the whole
truth about what happened with Dayne
what else might he have hidden it's also
interesting to see Howland wounded maybe
that's related to why he hasn't turned
up yet in the series because he is alive
at least in the books he's the lost
living survivor of the tower of joy and
people keep saying how great he is but
we still haven't seen him maybe he was
disabled by this wound somehow and has
at home either way we'll hopefully see
more of him soon there are lots of cool
theories about him
anyway after the fight we start getting
to the important bit Ned he is screaming
from the tower which is presumably Liana
because that's who he came looking for
but we don't know what's up like is she
in pain is she dying is she alone up
there just as we're about to find out
The Raven pulls bran out of the vision
so it looks like we'll have to wait a
couple more episodes to see what
happened in the tower but there is a
huge old theory about this
check out the r plus l equals j video
for details but another thing we learn
here is that Brown can affect the past
through his visions he calls out to Ned
and Ned hears him this could support the
idea that Willis became Hodor when bran
somehow messed with his mind in one of
these visions like maybe brand says her
daughter young Willis and that's where
the name Hodor originally comes from
like some kind of timey wimey Back to
the Future circular paradox type [ __ ]
and the point of this for brands
character could be to show him the
terrible potential of his power to give
him guilt and the restraint that
Bloodraven is trying to teach him at the
end of the same brand asks Bloodraven
what the point of all this training is
and he vaguely but dramatically says to
learn everything Daenerys Targaryen
arrives at phase Dothrak the sacred city
of the Dothraki and she's actually been
here before way back in season one it's
where she eats that horse heart she
meets the - Colleen the widows of dead
calls who strip her and demean her and
tell her that she may or may not be made
to join their happy little retirement
village depending on the results of a
big meeting of all the Dothraki callous
arse together that might sound bad for
Danny but having all the Dothraki in one
place with Danny's dragon on the way
might actually be an opportunity to take
control of a massive Dothraki Army this
will probably involve some Dothraki
getting barbecued and this - Colleen
woman is probably first on Danny's list
in marine Varys questions valor the
woman we saw working with the sons of
the harpy last season Varys seems to
play nice offering silver and Passage to
Pentos in return for information on the
harp
he says he doesn't torture and wouldn't
hurt a child but is this really how
Varys operates we know he lies
manipulates and kills will he really
keep his promises to valor or will he
dispose of her once he has what he wants
there's a lot of moral complexity to
Varys sir at least in the books
hopefully the show will reflect some of
that anyway serve Allah tells Varys that
the sons of the harpy are funded by
three cities Astapor yunkai and volantis
which does make sense because those
cities trade slaves when Danny banned
slavery when Varys tells us to Tyrion
missandei and grey worm there's talk of
war between marine and these other
cities in King's Landing we see the
creepy Qyburn with Varys as spies the
children he calls little birds in the
books
these children are mute Varys has their
tongues removed so that they can't share
his secrets but here in the show the
birds say that Varys is nice and gives
them sweets like Santa Claus with no
balls so yeah maybe the show is turning
Varys into more of a one-dimensional
good guy which would be a shame but the
fact that the little birds are included
at all in the show hints that they may
play some future role in fact that looks
like them in the trailer murdering us
certain someone for those have read the
books that might be the scene at the end
of dance then Cersei rolls in with her
entourage of the one-handed Kingslayer
and the zombie mountain she talks about
wanting to kill people and she mentions
her plans to demand a trial by combat
against the faith and that Robert strong
aka the mountain aka Gregor Clegane will
fight for her the question then is who
the champion for the faith will be who
could possibly stand against Robert
strong well there is a theory that a
certain gravedigger may rise to fight in
what's probably the most hyped
hypothetical fight in the fandom it'll
be [ __ ] crazy if it happens but
probably more fun if it's a surprise so
let's move on for now Cersei and Jaime
try to join the small Council but alehna
Tyrell the queen of sick burns talks
smack about Circe's incest mace Tyrell
dithers pycelle farts and Kevin leads
the council out of the room this is the
government of Westeros and it's in a
sari bloody state at this point Kevin
and maybe alone are the only people
really holding things to
then we see Tommen confront the high
Sparrow or lack I'm an angry Lannister
hear me roar I make violent threats just
like my mum and the high Sparrow is like
nah mate you're not a lion you're a
kitten now sit down and let's have a
chat about Jesus and Tommen's like yeah
okay let's do that try as he might
Tommen just isn't intimidating or cruel
like his parents he's sensitive and the
sparrow knows exactly how to play him
just like he undermines Cersei by
exploiting her pride and body and
sexuality and undermines Jaime by
showing that his physical power is
useless he controls Tommen by targeting
his insecurities about his relationship
with his mother and his responsibilities
as King Tommen is a kid in need of
guidance in need of a good father figure
the high Sparrow sees this and provides
carefully drawing Tommen into his own
ideology and control the high Sparrow is
not just a holy man he's a master
manipulator
so what's his end goal in Braavos ayuh
gets a training montage she uses her
senses to overcome a blindness she
detects poisons by smell she plays The
Lying Game and ultimately becomes a
stronger person she subtly threatens the
wife and gives her a good smack in the
face so they're really setting the
groundwork if a conflict between the two
eventually a man with Jackson's face
turns up and for the first time this
season we see jaqen and the wave
together in the same room showing that
there are at least two faceless men
around not just one swapping faces in
the books there seem to be at least nine
of them in total maybe that's true in
the show as well anyway in the end Eyre
gets her sight back the blind part of
her training is over and she's ready to
go kick ass whose ass we don't yet know
then Lord small John umba turns up at
Winterfell he's there to join up with
ramsay but he doesn't Neal doesn't swear
oaths he calls Randy's dad a [ __ ]
and sees right through Ramsay's lies so
right away Ramsay's rightly suspicious
of this guy
why should he trust him amber gives
Ramsay a gift
Rickon the youngest stock brother who
everyone forgot about and oh sure the
wildling who protected him after they
split from bran since everyone thinks
bran is dead Rickon is the last known
surviving male stock making him the
rightful Lord of Winterfell and a very
valuable captive for
especially after losing Sansa to show
that the kid really is Rickon Alma
presents the head of shaggy-dog richens
direwolf which is really sad shaggy was
there for Rickon when no one else was he
represents recons anger and wildness and
he showed so much promise in the books
as a vision of shaggy fighting a unicorn
on scar goes people hoped to see Rick on
ride shaggy dog into battle at
Winterfell
this wolf was just really metal and cool
so it's sad to see him go but it is
funny that in storytelling a shaggy dog
story is a long story that ends up being
pointless or anticlimactic so arguably
shaggy dog himself is a sort of a shaggy
dog story unless it's not really shaggy
some people have pointed out that the
head looks kind of small for a direwolf
so maybe it's just a normal wolf's head
and the umbers are secretly still loyal
to the Starks but this might just be
wishful thinking because in the second
trailer that is an umber banner flying
with the Bolton army so if anyone's up
to any northern conspiracy shenanigans
it'll probably be the manderlys who
Ramsay mentioned in the last episode
those guys have some of the best lines
in the series so get came for that but
in the meantime the things don't look
good for Rickon and oh sure
back at the wall Jon Snow kills the
people who killed him a kind of revenge
that not many people get to have is
actually kind of cool that Jon hangs
them because if Jon Snow is like Jesus
these guys elect Judas and in the Bible
Judas hangs himself depending on which
passage you read it's probably a
coincidence but still a cool connection
anyway it's hard not to respect alice'
for standing up for what he believed
until the very end he just wanted to
protect the watch and Olli a lot of
people wanted to see Olli dead
jokingly mostly but still it's hard to
be happy about a dead kid isn't it the
tragedy of all this drama on the wall is
that while these good men squabble
amongst themselves much greater threats
lie to the south and the north these are
the real enemies and right now the watch
isn't anywhere near ready
anyway after killing his killers John
hands command to Ed and says his watch
is ended the vows of the Nights Watch
say it shall not end until my death and
since John died he's now seen as freed
from his vows which is kind of a
[ __ ] technicality maybe this could
Cena's breaking his oath hashtag episode
title but either way it looks like we're
finally getting what's been wanted for a
long while John's gonna ride south to
Winterfell so this episode isn't as
massive as the last two no resurrections
great revelations dead kings or
destroyed houses and there's a lot of
setup here for future conflict this talk
of war and slavers Bay
Danny's threatening the - Colleen with a
dragon on the way a trial by combat is
coming in King's Landing and most
terrifying of all Sam's bringing his
girlfriend home to his parents brands
getting stroppy with his teacher is
getting struck with her teacher the
Bolton's have Rick on and Jon Snow's
watch is ended thank you for watching
please like and subscribe if you'd like
to see more and thank you to all patrons
supporting the channel including Sara
Cleary spencer bentley ryan steel city
dev William Armstrong Amy Cobb Dick's
Elias and G she is
you